thanks for coming guys my name is mike
Wolfson i'm i am going to talk about
android developer tools i recently well
we'll get into it just wanted to give
you a quick concept of what the agenda
is so you guys have an idea of what
we're going to be doing today i'm going
to start off with an introduction both
about myself and about the tools we're
going to talk about the ADB and command
line tools emulator talk about some
shortcuts for coding and then we'll talk
about performance monitoring and things
like that I just want to give you an
idea I've given this talk previously
I've done it a few times but this
particular slide deck came from oz con
their presentations are targeting 40
minutes which is not a lot of time so
I've expanded it quite a bit for this
presentation but I think it'll go about
targeting just about a little over an
hour hour and 15 minutes if you want to
ask questions go ahead and raise your
hand and you know interrupt obviously if
if I can't answer it or it's too much of
a digression we'll just move on and I'll
answer it afterwards I mentioned at
giving this talks a few times at ahs
khan and Devcon a few other places
generally I have had like demos in the
presentation when i did this talk 4oz
khan i put all the demos kind of it
slides and everything went so much
smoother so there won't be a lot of
demos but if there is something that in
particular you want to see you know we
can do that afterwards I'd be happy to
show you how to run any of the tools
specifically had run in any of the demos
any sort of questions so you know we'll
tackle that afterwards okay so I'm just
a little bit about me I guess the most
important thing about me is I run the
Phoenix chapter of the google developer
group I founded it I've run it for I
don't know 60 I know how many years but
anyway that's a run a google developer
group in phoenix
I love the community and I love just
getting people together to talk about
tools and stuff so I'm also a full-time
Android developer I currently work I
live in Phoenix I work for a company
here in Silicon Valley in san mateo
named epocrates there a healthcare point
of service appt some people may be heard
of them and I am a full-time Android
developer that's what I do in my day job
and that's also what I do for fun so
it's what I've been lucky enough to find
a job that allows me to do my hobby for
fun previous to that I've have about 15
years of experience mostly in enterprise
Java development so so for the first
book can anybody tell me what's unusual
about this picture
oh I see ya tic tacs no that's an ice
cream sandwich okay well actually the
statue is not correct and more this the
jelly bean statue has changed this
picture was taken the day that the jelly
bean statue was unveiled and they
changed the top of that it doesn't have
a clear dome anymore now it's got a
their green thing on it so there will be
other chances to get to get it get books
i also want to mention um if you guys
don't particularly want a hard copy of
the book i'm more than happy to make the
soft copy available for download for
free so just keep keep that that's great
so obviously that's between you and me
and not O'Reilly but anyway it's but I
do want you guys to know that if you
really are interested in the book come
up and talk to me afterwards i'll give
you the URL where you can go download i
have all four different types of drm
free books in my dropbox so i'll share
that link so um so uh you know i just
want you guys to know that okay we
talked enough about this I just
published this book for O'Reilly it's
been about about four or five months so
I've always been passionate about the
Android developer tools they sometimes
have some challenges and understanding
how to use them and how to run them so I
figured it would be a good topic to
share because I think it's really
important I think the tools are really
fantastic and the project and the team
are really great I think the discovery
and usability of the tools not usability
but the discovery is it can be
challenging so that's why I wrote the
book the other thing is I am active
developer and for fun I have an app in
the market called droid of the day it is
a app of the day app basically every day
you'll get a notification of a new app
it's been in the market for quite a
while it's got a decent
downloads and it's free so if you're
interested in apps check it out the
other thing I'll mention is if you are
an app developer and you'd like to see
your app featured this is a good way to
get visibility and part of the reason
that I run this app is because I like to
help independent developers find an
audience which can be challenging in the
Play Store if you're a developer let me
know and i'll see you about feature in
your app ok a real quick i just wanted
to tell you a little bit about some
presentation resources these slides are
all available up on SlideShare so
they're available there's an old copy
there now after this presentation i'll
make sure i upload the newest copy but
that's what the URL be there the other
thing i want to mention is when writing
the book and for this presentation I did
generate a project android project that
is designed to help run the demos and
generate examples so it's up here at
github so if you want to download that
that should help you run all the demos
and you'll see throughout the
presentation there are certain times
where I might reference that so in
regards to that anytime that you see a
gray box down at the bottom with you
know in that style that's going to infer
it's a tool it's something for you to
try at home or a command to type in so
you see that box that you keep you in to
know that you have homework
okay so that's enough about me let's
talk a little bit about the tools and
then we'll get into the nitty-gritty of
actually using the tools so the first
thing I want to mention about the
Android developer tools is that they are
free and open source so you know I don't
wanna make a political statement about
Android but the Android AOSP is
realistically not open source they don't
take they don't take submissions and
they it's not developed in the open
source they give it to the open source
community after it's been developed
difference is the Android developer
tools are developed completely in the
open there is a open branch that you can
go check out the latest revisions of the
code and they do take submissions if you
have a fix or something they do accept
submissions so it's a much different
sort of project than Android and the
other thing that's important to mention
is its run independent of Android you
they're not necessarily the same team
they're run differently they have
different schedules and they have
different um they have different kind of
ways of operations so they're very very
different tools on android com is the
location where you can get all the
information you need about the tools I
will also say this about the tools
development team is they're very open
and very available you'll see that
they're answering questions in group
chat there they're not very secretive
and they're very open so it's a really
great team and they seem to be run
really well and I think they've done a
great job okay so let's talk about the
tools a little bit I think you guys are
probably all familiar with the
eclipse-based ADT that's basically the
tools that we've been using for many
years now very very stable very rock
solid at Google i/o this year they
introduced the android studio android
studio is a new flavor of Android
ide and it lives alongside of the adt
android developer tools now i do want to
say something very important and i have
their verified this this doesn't mean
that the eclipse based tools are going
away it just means that there's a new
flavor involved we can talk about why
they're doing this if you'd like after
the presentation but if when this first
came out a lot of people thought man you
know now i gotta learn a new tool
eclipse is going away yes absolutely
torn or be a xavier de Rocher those are
the two big big names that i think are
the most representative so it's
important to know that just because they
introduced android studio doesn't mean
that android developer tools are going
away the eclipse based tools are
extremely stable they're very
feature-rich and they have a huge user
base there would be no reason for them
to abandon that and to be just to drive
this point home they're not abandoning
eclipse so so let's um give a little
analogy of the difference here between
the two tools so i kind of consider
eclipse like a you know a gold camry
station wagon really reliable rock-solid
is going to get you where you need to go
but you may not look that great gettin
there and it may not be that much fun to
drive whereas the android studio is much
like this ferrari f430 that is rock and
fast and handles great but if you don't
know what you're doing you're gonna wrap
yourself around a tree
yeah um android studio is definitely the
sexy hotness quick but if you don't know
what you're doing or you don't
necessarily have a reason to be using
android studio i would strongly suggest
that you stick with the Eclipse based
tools for now they're stable there's a
huge community of support around them
and you know great all the questions are
answered things like that and we will
talk just a little bit more about what
android studio is and um do you have a
question I don't know about a percentage
I do think some of the command some of
the tools are common but uh I don't
think they share a lot together but I
would have no way to know the percentage
oh sure the sorry about that the
question was how much code is shared
between intelligent between Android
studio and ADT and the answer is I don't
know okay so let's talk a little bit
about Android studio what what it is so
that you kind of know some of the key
differences between that and the Eclipse
based tools so Android studio is based
on the IntelliJ IDE so a completely
different IDE has different key commands
different way of doing things it also
implements under the covers the new
Gradle based build system now I just
want to mention about the greater base
build system you don't have to use
Android studio for the four Gradle you
can also run your builds your Clips
builds using the Gradle build and if you
look in the export file export you can
actually export out of Eclipse you can
export your Gradle build file so if you
want to play with Gradle which is a
whole nother discussion that we're not
going to get into a cradle is I would
strongly suggest that you start thinking
about Gradle i mentioned that android
studio is not replacing a
ET Gradle is replacing aunt so they have
said that Gradle is their future build
system and that and is deprecated so you
want to start using Gradle and Gradle is
really well designed for and write it
allows you to generate all sorts of
different builds just right from the
build tool things like that so again i'm
not sure i'd suggest using android
studio I would suggest checking out
Gradle and trying to come up to speed on
that I think that will benefit you one
really great thing about android studio
is they have a really rich visual editor
so they have a real-time visual editor
that will allow you to make changes in
your code and look at the changes as
they be represented in your UI directly
so they also have a really rich
drag-and-drop UI builder it's clear that
that's like something that you get
really good out of um Android studio the
other thing is they have really good
integration with google cloud services I
haven't done this myself but what they
demoed at i/o was you could look at your
data model right mouse click on the data
model and generate code that would allow
you to create a sink to the Google cloud
services so pretty cool stuff and no
doubt Android studio is going to really
keep innovating and we're going to see a
lot of movement with Android studio and
not as much as ADT but for now and this
is the last bullet it's still an early
access preview which means it's alpha
for the most part not even beta it is
buggy it is certainly in flux and it is
not for the weak of heart so so I think
statement made
yeah i would suggest using Gradle now
yes I it is stable yes I don't know it's
still also pretty dynamic but i would
suggest using Gradle now and I do think
it is stable enough to be production
quality there's probably going to be
some features that are implemented yet
but maybe if you're an early adopter you
can help drive some of those things by
communicating those needs and things so
I sir done this is of earlier can I just
see a show of hands of how many people
are active Android developers now great
and how many of you people are really
comfortable with the tools and think you
really know how they work okay uh well I
do cover a lot of the basics and I added
some some more advanced stuff to this
presentation so hopefully I will you
know ab stuff of interest to everybody
well yes intellij is an IDE just like
eclipse so you can do different projects
of all different flavors web projects
c++ projects
okay so historically if you wanted to
install the Android developer tools you
had to download a bunch of different
components the plug in the IDE the Java
etc and then wire them all together
fortunately this has all gone away and
now they for both Android studio and
eclipse there is a downloadable bundle
and this allows you to just download one
platform specific zip file install it on
your system and everything works so the
reason I want to include the the reason
I included this in these slides is
because it's really important if you're
working with an old eclipse if you're
working with an old Android installation
and you're scared to touch it and every
time you upgrade it it's fickle and you
have issues wipe it away delete that
completely and start with a bundle
because it is so easy in fact frequently
if I do have those problems that I can't
get an upgrade to work or whatever I
wipe away my android installation
completely download a brand new bundle
which is going to have all the current
latest code already already in there and
working so don't be afraid of the bundle
and if you are having any challenges
don't be afraid to just wipe your system
and start fresh the only challenge with
the bundle is it's about 400 megabytes
download so the biggest problem is
getting that big download the first time
after after that it's as easy as could
be okay so I'm going to move on to the
Android debug bridge Android debug
bridge is kind of what the name says it
is a bridge that allows you to debug
your Android device from your computer
so this is basically a command line tool
and also a communication tool that
allows us to interact with our Android
devices the important thing to note here
is in android
a Android test device can be an emulator
or it can be an actual physical device
and for the most part there's not a
whole lot of difference between those
two things so this is one of those cases
where you see gray box that allows you
to these are some commands I would
encourage you to try on your own later
obviously adb help is super simple but
you can see the kind of things that you
can do with adb you can push files from
your device you can pull files you can
install an APK and run an APK there's a
lot of more advanced stuff you can do
you can actually install an APK and run
a single activity and that activity
doesn't have to be the main activity in
your manifest the one that you know is
is marked as your main activity ton of
flexibility now the cool thing is
because these are command-line tools
that flexibility is available to you to
script or without any sort of rich you I
I assume most of you guys have used adb
the other really common use for a BB is
if you're Rahming and rooting your phone
obviously a DB is the main tool you use
to do that to unlock your bootloader to
push files onto the phone things like
that so there's a ton of stuff you can
do uh I'm sorry the one last thing I
wanted to point out was this one at the
bottom which actually allows you to well
there's two things those two last
bullets the first bullet adb shell
allows you to open a shell command on
your android device and operate any of
the commands that are involved in a
shell LS MV etc etc now the shell that
comes with Android is in a complete
linux shell it doesn't have all the
commands that a regular linux shell has
but you can do a whole lot and adb shell
allows you to actually remote into your
device and do any sort of things that
you want look at this system inspect
files etc etc but the really cool thing
it also allows you to do is you can open
a SQL Lite command and introspect your
databases so if you
are doing database command and you want
to figure out within your tables your
table structures etc etc there's a
sequel lights command that allows you
just as if you were using sequel light
on you know any other system so the
other really important thing that we do
with a DB is logcat I'm sure you guys
are all familiar with logcat but i would
guess that you're not familiar with all
the things that it can do so i just want
to run through a really quick example of
some simple stuff in law cat explain how
it works and try some advanced stuff so
the first thing you can do with law
can't log cat has to sort of concepts
the first concept is a verbosity level
just like you guys I assume you guys
have used log4j where you can set the
debug level too verbose debug etc warned
that same concept exists in and right so
you can set when you create a log
statement so like this one in my java
class you can set a robo city level in
this case i have d sets of debug but the
cool thing about logcat is you can also
associate a tag with your log message so
in this case I have this my tag tag and
then the log message what this allows
you to do is you can filter based on the
tags that you create in your code so
generally what you do is when you're
writing your code you create tags that
are specific to functional areas that
you want to test then you can filter
based on those tags and see how your
code progresses through that particular
functional area so a quick example this
is a logcat where I have not performed
any sort of filtering based on it if
again i'm sure you guys had looked at
log log cat messages there's a ton of
stuff that goes through especially if
you're using a real physical device
there's all sorts of system events
happening you want to see what you're
looking at you got to look real closely
and got to look real careful so you can
see I have those tags but you know if I
didn't have them highlighted here they'd
be pretty hard to figure out where they
were
so all you'll do is if you do want to
see the something if you do want to see
law cat related to your particular tags
you just issue a command adb logcat my
tag colon 0 then the important second
part of that command is the not call in
the star I'm sorry so tag colon star the
first before the colon that is the tag
that part after the tag is if what
verbosity level you want seen so in this
case i say i want all verbosity levels
for tag and the second important thing
is for I want to silence everything else
so that's what the star call and ask
means and when I do that you can see
that now I can very clearly see exactly
what I'm looking for and all the fluff
is gone now that's pretty cool you can
filter based on a single tag but the
important thing is you can filter based
on multiple tags so in this case this
example shows I'm 10 I'm filtering based
on my own unique tag I want to see my
tag but I'm also interested in seeing
how my tag released relates to package
manager so basically you create that
command might add colon asterisk package
manager colon asterix and then don't
forget the asterisk colon asked to
silence everything else and you'll see
now I have just the information about
the two tags that I'm interested in and
you could create as many different
filter sets as you want you can string
multiple sets and of course you could
also filter based on a tag and a
verbosity level combined so there's a
ton of flexibility and if you design
your tags if you design your log
messages with these tags in mind it is a
indispensable tool when you're trying to
debug it allows you to really drill down
to see just the stuff you care about and
remove all the other fluff
so that's just basic logcat did some
have a question okay so that's just
basic logcat but you can do a whole
bunch of other stuff with law cat and I
leave this slide for you guys to drive
in your home you could also if you're
interested in only a particular buffer
like radio like the radio buffer or the
events buffer or the main buffer which
is the default in this case you can
specify a particular buffer that you
want to see so you can filter so you're
only seeing the radio buffer you that's
the only messages you care about
obviously that depends on the type of
code you're writing there's also a
variety of predefined output formats so
brief is the default and that specifies
different parameters that will be output
but time is a really useful one that
appends a time which isn't in the basic
log functionality so and again you can
add these command lines these
command-line arguments in addition to
the tags so as you can see there's a
really rich rich set of logcat
functionality the last thing I'm not
going to demo but is really worth
exploring is the logcat tab in Eclipse
this allows you to save a bunch of
filter sets and tag sets if so you don't
have to type them every time you can
actually save a tag set and click on it
and it will filter based on that it and
the other really cool thing that the law
cab viewer in Eclipse has is a reg ex
editor so you can actually search your
logs using regular expressions which
again is really rich so as developers
i'm sure you guys i'll realize that logs
are really important especially when
you're in the midst of trying to figure
something out and lock at really allows
you to get at exactly what what you want
to see
good okay so that's logcat let's now
talk a little bit about emulators I want
to address first of all some of the
capabilities of emulators and then we'll
talk about some of the limitations first
thing you can do with an emulator is you
can simulate telephony so you can
simulate latency or connectivity or
simulate events as in SMS or a phone
call you can't actually make a phone
call but you can simulate a phone call
you can simulate location including a
KML or a path you can specify a single
location that your emulator is supposed
to emulate you can emulate a variety of
different hardware now that's the
important thing and the reason why we
want to use an emulator is there's a lot
of Android devices in this world I think
the last time i looked at my droid of
the day console that my app currently
supports like 3,000 different devices
even if i was really really rich i
wouldn't be able to purchase all three
thousand of those devices to test with
so using an emulator allows me to
simulate a variety of different hardware
configurations so that i can at least
get close and now for the most part now
there are some limitations i guess which
we'll get to in a second on emulators
good
Isis
so the question was if you want to
emulate different resolutions of devices
can you do that and how accurate is it
that you absolutely can do you can
actually i'll show you in a second when
we're setting when i show you how you
set up an ABD you can specify preset
resolutions or you can actually create
your own so for resolution you
absolutely can emulate it exactly right
what you can't do it we'll get to in a
second what you can't do is emulate the
skins that the manufacturers put on
their devices so TouchWiz motoblur I
guess I don't know if that exists
anymore but a TouchWiz or LG skin those
you cannot emulate in a emulator well
actually that's now a little different
thing so the question was there's a
process that you can use with the Nexus
10 using adb you can actually have the
nexus 10 emulate different resolution
resolution sizes using us some commands
that so the question was is is that a
better approach or is using an emulator
better approach and the answer is it
depends good
it is lat long it takes lat long KML and
one other type of format of um I can't
think in the third deep GPX is that I
what is it
okay there's three types i'm not sure if
the third uh yes
the question is does the arm ambulation
basically does it perform the same as a
real arm phone is that your question
so the question is does the emulator
perform the same as a device I think I'm
going to but the answer is no definitely
not if you're doing really performance
testing you probably want to use a real
device there's so many variables in an
emulator both the device the physical
device it's on your computer how many
other things that's working on etc etc
the performance is not going to be
accurate to what you would see on a real
device so
so the comment is in addition to AMD you
also may want to test using the Intel
chipset because there are Intel phones
around and I'm actually going to discuss
that in a second because there's other
advantages in addition to just emulating
Intel chipsets so I am actually going to
touch that in a second last thing you
can do with emulator is you can do media
actions but only audio not video you
cannot do video on a emulator some of
the limitations of things you cannot do
on a emulator include Google services
like Gmail or the Play Store things like
that you can now there are ways to hack
that onto the emulator so there are ways
to work around this issue but out of the
box it is not designed to run Play
services and I think there's obstacles
and there will continue to be obstacles
they don't they don't want that on
ambulator you can't make real phone
calls I think we already kind of
discussed that certain graphics support
again this is getting back to kind of
what we were discussing before the
performance is not the same so if you're
doing a game or something that requires
very precise graphics performance the
emulator is probably not the right place
for you to be testing testing your your
functionality the other thing that's
limited on a emulator is touch events
you have a mouse to interact with your
device so multi-touch or certain other
operations are limited you just can't
can't I can't do that
multi
so yeah so the question is using either
Vidya a touchscreen monitor or a
computer that has a multi touch keypad
will they support multitouch in the
future I don't know the answer to what
they're going to support the future
there is a adb bridge that allows you to
use your device as a touch sensor for
your emulator so again it's one of as
I'm sure everybody in the room knows and
anybody that's done professional and
right knows when the question is does
android do it the answer is always yes
because it's such an open platform
there's always some way to get what you
want done if you have enough time money
and resources you can do pretty much
anything you want with these things but
you know out of the box it's not
supported there is limited accessory
integration you can use USB and
headphones and the other big limitation
of emulators is they're really slow slow
to start they can be slow to deploy too
and they can be slow to run so i am
going to show you some tips on how you
speed it up but again I'm sure everybody
in here knows when you start your
emulator it's time to go grab a cup of
coffee or you know go check out Facebook
or whatever because you're going to be
waiting you know it can take three
minutes for an emulator to start up okay
yeah go ahead
so the question is is it possible to
emulate bluetooth I don't know the
answer to that I would suspect not
because that mmm I don't know as we say
because you're the computer hardware
would require bluetooth of course most
computers now have bluetooth so I don't
know if you can emulate Bluetooth that's
good question that you get the first
alright so as I mentioned there's lots
and lots of Android devices in this
world you know every device on this
screen it runs Android and or at these
interfaces with Android so it's really
important that you understand emulators
and understand how you can use them so
that you can be able to test on the
biggest variety of devices possible I
think in a professional world this
doesn't excuse you not having a variety
of actual devices to test on but
emulators will get you a good distance
of the way so let's talk for real quick
we'll take a quick diversion let's say
that you don't want to use an emulator
you can use almost any Android device as
a test device there may be very few
exceptions but for the most part any
Android device works as a test device
the only thing you need to do is enable
this check box in your device settings
app so basically you just need to allow
your device to run applications from
outside of the Play Store and you can
run any app you want on your Android
device I'm sure there are some maybe I
assume probably Kindle Fire doesn't
allow you to do that some other things
but for the most part any device is
available now the challenge is after OS
4.1 they hid I'm sorry so so that
particular function actually I'm not
sure if that function is hidden in
developer tools or not but that's the
step one step two that you're probably
also going to want to do is good okay
great so the allowing apps from non Play
Store is not hidden in the developer
tools but you're going to want to access
the developer tools enable the developer
tools on your device so that you can
debug directly into the device hook up a
USB things like that in addition to some
other things now the challenge is in OS
4.1 they hid that so that this used to
be an item that was available in your
settings
you just had to go find it and enable it
now it's hidden so the way to get there
now is you click on the about phone
button seven times and at the end of the
seventh time you get a nice message that
says congratulations you're now a
developer and that that that shows up in
your in your list so yeah so the comment
is once you start hitting it you'll see
click 7 click 7 times 6 times 5 times 4
times I'm not sure but I think that
might move actually what you have to
click but basically I thought I might
have had to click the build for KitKat
okay okay good so anyway that's what you
want to do now the cool thing is
basically what I just told you is how
you can use your phone as a test device
but the developer options that I just
showed you how to enable have a ton of
really great functionality in them in it
and it's all based on testing on your
device itself so obviously USB debugging
allows you to hook a USB device into
your phone that's pretty normal but the
other things you can do in there and I
really encourage you guys to go look in
the developer options and just start
playing with these things are allowing
mock locations so that allows you to
specify you know some of the locations
we were just talking about strict mode
allows you to flash your phone it
flashes your phone red when you're doing
operations on the main UI thread which
as good android developers you know you
never want to do long-running operations
on the UI thread so there's just a check
box there that allows you to quickly see
and it's really obvious in fact i run
this all the time on i have strict mode
enabled on my device all the time and
it's interesting to see how many you
know apps are being bad but as a
developer it's really great for you to
be able to see when your app is being
bad and it's really in your face you can
show touches so if you're doing a
presentation or something that will
highlight the
touch points you're pressing on your
device you can't change the animation
and transition scale so that you can get
a closer look at the you know animations
that you're using and if you're
debugging those you can also select and
this is just a small list there's a lot
of stuff in there you can also one don't
keep activities so this will kill the
activity as soon as it closes which
allows you to mess with state if you're
you know doing particular particular
operations so the developer tools are
really the developer options that are on
the phone are really really rich and
something that most people don't use but
something that you should and they're
really low risk to play let's just go
enable your phone go start playing with
those things for your I mean you're not
going to mess anything up basically
these are just visual cues and things
but I think you'll learn a lot running
your app and enabling some of these
different developer options okay so
remember all these devices and remember
that we can particularly that we can't
possibly afford to buy them all let's
say that we just want to concentrate on
that top little area at the phones and
tablets that's when we really want to
start talking about using emulators to
emulate some of these different physical
devices and so I want to go ahead and
talk a little bit about how you set up
an emulator some of the different
options you have and also how we go
about speeding up emulator thing like
things like that okay so the first step
you want to do when you're creating an
emulator is I you're going to create
something called an Android virtual
device so this is basically just a
representation of the physical device
that allows you to specify a variety of
different things that you want your
particular emulator to look like so
you'll notice I you know in this case I
have it emulating a Galaxy Nexus I can
specify which particular OS I want to
target I can specify which particular
CPU I want to target currently you can
select between
arm Intel and a third nips you can
specify hardware keyboard things like
that if it has a camera if it doesn't
have a camera memory footprint and you
can also specify you know SD card things
like that now there's a couple options
at the bottom that I want to
particularly call out because they are
particularly useful and particularly
functional the first one is used host
GPU so this allows you to if your
computer has a GPU it allows you to
leverage that to improve the performance
of your emulator so it will attach to
it'll attach that GPU I think that
that's only available if you're using
the hack some emulator the Intel is that
correct I think you can only use the
host GPU if you're using an Intel
emulator which we'll get to in a second
but the other really great thing is
snapshot so if you guys know what
virtual if you guys have ever used you
know any virtual machine VM ware etc
when you close the virtual machine there
is functionality that allows you to save
a snapshot of that virtual machine so
the next time you bring it up it brings
it up to that same place that's all
that's exactly what this this snapshot
functionality does because these are
basically virtual machines anyway these
emulator images so when you're creating
your abd if you check that snapshot
button it allows you to enable these
snapshot functionality then when you're
launching your abd you can select these
three buttons here at these three
buttons here at the bottom which allow
you to use the snapshot so the first
time you bring up your emulator you will
wipe user data and then have this saved
snapshot button enabled so generally
what I do is I bring up an emulator from
scratch I go through the various startup
that it presents you like there's the
overlays that safe you know the Android
overlays it's a you know press ok to put
your put apps here or whatever I go
through all those startup options so I
have a fresh emulator that has been
started up and I've gotten through all
these startup dialogues and then I kill
it right there so that I have a pristine
emulator and has been started up and is
in brand-spanking-new fresh state next
time when i start my avd my emulator
instead of having wipe user data
selected i have launched from snapshot
selected in and not saved a snapshot so
next time when i start up this emulator
it's going to start it up using the
snapshot that i just took and the great
thing is it changes the startup time
from you know like i said 34 minutes 2
seconds maybe 10 seconds 20 seconds if
you're not using snapshots this will in
fact if you leave here now you just
learn something really good snapshots
will save you a lot of time the other
thing you can do using snapshots is if
you do have a particular state in your
app that you want to test repeatedly you
can bring your app up to that state and
then save that's Nate state as your
snapshot so you can always bring up your
fresh emulator to exactly the point in
the code that you need to test ok so we
kind of touched on some of these things
before but there are alternatives to
using the Android emulators first one is
Intel's hexam so this allows you to
create emulators using the Intel chipset
so if your computer is running an intel
chip instead of an AMD chip this is a
great way to this is a great thing to do
now performance wise you know it's fine
but the Intel hexham emulator is much
faster to start up and much faster to
deploy to so right there in and of
itself it is a much faster experience to
be using the Intel hack some emulator
big giant limitation of Hexham is that
it doesn't support the play I'm sorry
the google google api is it only
supports the android api s so if you're
doing anything that requires the google
api is GCM or some of the other options
available to android until accident is
unfortunately not available to use so if
you're not using the google api's until
aksam is really great i would really
strongly suggest you use it it supports
snapshots just the same as the standard
emulator so there is also another
newcomer on the block called genymotion
and they provide basically a turnkey
options for generating emulators so
instead of with hack some or the
standard android emulator i have to go
through create the emulator avd that i
think is appropriate to my needs start
it up at cetera et cetera genymotion
provides a really rich gooey that allows
you to start from a variety of
pre-configured emulator images the cool
thing about previous version of
genymotion and this is just changed with
their new release is the last version of
genymotion actually did support full
Play services so it supported the Play
Store you could create a google account
on a genuine motion emulator all those
things unfortunately it didn't last long
because I they just announced in their
next release that that's going away I'm
pretty sure and of course we don't know
because genymotion is a closed project
I'm pretty sure they use Intel Hexham
it's really fast it's really robust the
cool thing about both Intel hacks and
genymotion and this is one of those
things that you might not key in on
early but really makes a difference in
the development process is the
deployment speed so it takes a little
bit of time to deploy to an android
emulator both hack some and genymotion
the deployment time is is much more
rapid so
those are some things that you might not
key in on early but it makes a big
difference especially in your daily
development cycle that you know you're
deploying deploying deploying so what's
like this guy yeah arm sorry the
question is I've been saying Andy do I
mean arm the answer is yes Android
studio uses the same MO emulators and I
I'm pretty sure you can use a you know
genymotion or hack some as well on
Android studio ok so that's enough of
the tools let's talk about coding there
are a ton of really great tools built
into the adt that if you use them will
save you a lot of time and a lot of
mistakes android as again you guys all
know can be pretty challenging there's a
lot of moving parts you have your xml
file your java file you have other
external configuration files for certain
operations that you're using a fragment
you have multiple java files all
connected it can be really challenging
and if you mess up one piece one
attribute in that xml file it can be a
bear to try to debug that there are a
ton of automated code generation tools
that i'll show you in a moment that at
least allow you to stub out your initial
code so that you're not fighting the
basic stuff and you can concentrate on
the business logic and the important
stuff as opposed to creating these sub
foundations
gradle how so the comment is great Oh
made this easy oh yeah so right yeah
Gradle does make some of these
configuration things easier because of
the nature of their resource you can
build multiple apks from different
resources within yeah so there's really
great support for java and xml editing
that you can take advantage of and
there's also a really rich robust visual
editor that most people probably don't
use because it used to kind of suck
basically okay so let's talk a little
bit about some of the cogeneration
wizards that you can use and why you
really should be using these things so
to access any of these um wizards you
can hit file new at the top or ctrl or
command on Apple and that will bring up
this wizard selection you can see
there's a variety of different things
you can do in there you can create an
icon set you can create a simple
activity you can create an Android XML
file a variety of different things
there's these are really robust tools
that will allow you to just create a
simple code that you can then go in and
fill out yourself later so let's let's
start with the first example and that's
Android icon set so again you guys all
know what a hassle it is to come up with
all the different versions of your icons
you need to first of all figure out what
size they need to be what folder do they
need to go into do I have xx xx hdpi for
this one etc etc it's a real challenge
not to mention trying to communicate
that to your graphic designer or someone
else on your team this Android icon set
and the other thing i will mention about
this particular tool is there's a really
in fact this tools good that's built
into eclipse but this tool is based on a
web project called Android asset
studio Android asset studio remember
that it's a website that not only will
allow you to create your different
resolution images but it also Android
assets through the website allows you to
create frames for your screenshots or a
variety of other different really great
things so this is just a subset of what
is on that website but let me just show
you what this what this what this
particular thing allows you to do so
once you've selected create an icon set
it's going to allow you it's going to
bring up this wizard basically what this
wizard allows you to do is you could
select an image that's your own icon
that you can go select from anywhere on
your system clipart this is the android
standard clipart so you know if you want
to make sure that your settings icon
matches what the Android settings icon
is it's all there for you and it's built
right in or you could create a text one
which is what is shown here in this
example so you can select your different
icon what you want your icon to look
like you can specify colors change all
sorts of different things change the
padding when you press finish it
actually will create the icons and place
them within your project in the folders
they're supposed to go so it's going to
create a ldpi hdpi etc image in the
proper resolution and also it's going to
put those in the proper folders with the
proper name so the best way to import
images into your system even if you're
develop designer is given it to you is
bring up the image using that the image
option and then allow Android I'm sorry
assets to do or asset to put that into
your your project for you this saves a
whole lot of time and just another
workflow thing that I use that has been
very successful for me when I'm creating
my graphics I generally know what name I
want to use and what graphics I need so
what I'll do is I'll create a stubbed
out crap
just like this maybe a a or something
red and ugly name it the proper thing
put it in my resource folder then I
actually give that resource folder to my
graphic designer and say here's what I
need and they know exactly what size
images they need to do and they know
exactly the names so they can then put
all those images into that resource zip
give it back to me I copied into my
project and I'm done there's no imports
and all the names match and all the
sizes match so that's something that has
taken me a long time to come up with but
saves a whole lot of time it's really
challenging to communicate all the
different resolutions okay so that's a
droid assets to that's that's creating
an asset and that's really really useful
I suggest everybody use that you can
also generate great code with with this
with these Wizards and here's one of the
more complicated ones and it's a very
common use case and that's a multiple
fragments with a list view on one side
and a detail view on the other side and
if you guys know about android
development there's an adapter involved
there's a two activity there's an
activity two fragments and then all the
wiring that goes between those things
some XML files there's a lot going on
here this wizard allows you to walk
through a couple different questions
specify the names of the items you want
and the activities that you're creating
and it will generate the stubs for your
the code that you want to generate and
place that directly into your project so
even you know it's just a great first
step to allow you to stub out all the
things that wiring and the hard stuff
and get too down to the nitty-gritty of
writing code and ton of stuff to explore
in this in these code wizards I the
other thing I just want to mention so if
you're not happy with the code wizards
that they provide you can actually
create your own so frequently in the
development process we create our own
sort of frameworks and can
opponents that fit our particular
business case you can actually create
your own of template and allow your
developers to just use the template to
stub out these foundations so really
useful and it's sort of automation
things that just make the development
process so much more efficient and so
much more effective the last thing I
might mention about generating code this
way is it's all generated to code
compliant Android design patterns right
so the naming standards are matched the
division of workload etc so it's a
really great way to get started wanted
to highlight a six of the most important
keystrokes I use in Eclipse and these
are ones that I use all the time the
first one you guys probably know about
and that's code completion control or
command space this works in both Java
and in XML so if you're trying to figure
out what attributes you need in your XML
file was that wrap content or fill
parent or match parents I don't forget
Android colon width equals control space
and it'll give you the list of all your
different options that you can um put in
there so that works in both java and xml
and i'm sure you guys already know about
that one if you don't that right change
your life one that you probably don't
know about that's also extremely useful
and that's kind of universal is control
command one so if you highlight anywhere
in XML or Java you highlight a
particular component and hit command one
it's going to provide context-sensitive
help based on what it is that you've
selected so in some cases it may allow
you to extract that Exim that string to
the strings file you know we don't want
to leave hard-coded strings in our
Android files we want to extract those
two streams to xml that's something this
will allow you to do but depending on
what it is that you've selected it will
provide context specific things so there
may be refactoring help if you're if
you're on a layout parent or depending
on what you're doing so if you need help
command will highlight something command
one and it will provide you a lot of
different functionality and then the
last one on this this page is a command
shift F this allows you to reformat your
code to change indentation or change the
formatting the cool thing is this is has
specific functionality for XML it will
change your formatting change your tabs
etc so everything lines up it will also
reorder your XML attributes so if you
generally you want width and height to
be the very top attributes and I'm sorry
ID with height to be the top attributes
etc etc there's an order that you want
your attributes in and if coders not
careful the attributes are all out of
order ctrl shift F will actually reorder
all the attributes so that they are in
exactly the order that the Android
design standards specify and and if you
don't like that order you can specify
your own so command ship def is really
useful both in java and xml to ensure
that your formatting is consistent with
you know consistent i guess consistent
with android and also consistent across
all your entire project a great
navigation so these items were key
combinations that will allow you to
create code and speed through some of
these things this page covers navigation
commands so the first one I want to talk
about is command oh so anywhere within a
XML file or Java file if you hit command
o it will show you a outline view of
your code with the methods highlighted
so you can quickly just navigate with
your arrow key to the method that you
want rather than trying to search
through your code and scrolling up and
down
commando quickly look for the method you
want to go to click on it and you're
there another great way to navigate
around a project is command shift our or
t actually which has a command shift T
has a more robust filter set command
shift are from anywhere in your system
you can start typing the name of a file
you're looking for and if you're using
camel case you just use the first letter
so a camel case means out you know
uppercase c OU de uppercase P ro JCT you
can type CP and it will find that code
project file so command shift r is a
really great way to quickly find
different files that you're looking for
and then the last one that's really
useful is all chip a this allows you to
quickly run or debug your app without
having to you know right mouse click on
the project run as or I don't know if
you guys ever noticed but there's a
little play symbol up in the Eclipse
toolbar that allows you to also run
really quick that's another quick way to
do it all today allows you to UM quickly
run your app from anywhere okay so
that's um commands shortcuts I now want
to talk a little bit about the visual
editor my guess is and this was the case
with me anybody that tried the visual
editor years ago decided that it's just
not very good it puts a budget code it
doesn't really work you're going to
struggle with trying to get things lined
up the way you want them to be etc etc
the tool is much much better now
basically it allows you to drag and drop
components from the left-hand drawer
right onto your palette and you can
arrange all your components as you want
it also allows on the right-hand side
these property editors allow you to very
quickly select different properties on
different components within your
within your UI so if you have a button
and you select it the properties will
allow you to specify gravity or with or
any of those things instead of need to
type them you can go through these
selection criteria and quickly select a
you know whatever it is that you want
but the one thing that I really want to
highlight so let's say that all right
Mike that all sounds pretty cool but I'm
a code or I like to do stuff by hand you
still really should be checking out this
visual editor for this bar here because
what this bar allows you to do is within
the IDE it allows you to change the
visual style representative of what
you're looking at in addition to as I
have set up here now and now you'll see
actually you can look at how your app
will look on multiple devices so if
you'll see in this screen I have a 3.2
hvga image a 5.1 wvga a 10.1 wxga image
and i can quickly look at exactly how my
app is going to render on all of those
devices in one place so the way that you
get there is where it's selected nexus
one you can go into that menu and it
will allow you to select which of the
different images you want to preview
your app on in theory you can actually
make changes in real time and see how
that's going to lay out and all of those
different in all of those different
image sizes
so the question is years ago people use
tools like Troy draw or some other
different tools to to stub out their
visual UI is this good enough now that
you don't need to use that I think the
answer is yes there's a really robust
set of things you can do the other thing
i will mention on this is in addition to
specifying different resolution screens
that you want to look at you can also
specify api levels and you can also this
so you can specify api levels using this
a selection or you can use this one to
actually look at your
internationalization so if you have
enabled you know german language french
language etc on your app you can
actually select those from this
drop-down and see how your app lines up
when you're using german characters or
something and obviously that's really
important because certain language
character sets are bigger than others
this allows you very quickly to modify
your UI and understand exactly how it's
going to look you know right here really
quick there's no deploy cycle there's no
fiddling with your phone them to change
the locale it's all just right here so
even if you're not going to use the
visual editor to drag and drop
components and select properties or I
would really highly suggest that at
least when you're testing that you bring
your app into this visual editor and
play with the different resolutions and
things ok so we're coming up to the last
section and that's performance testing
and performance monitoring so the first
thing that I wanted to make everyone
aware of that you might not know is
there something called the tools monitor
so if you type tools monitor from your
you know if you have Android home set
you don't need to put the path it will
you guys know what DBMS is the different
tools that allow you to you know
monitor actually allows you to run all
the DDMS tools external to eclipse so if
i'm going to show you that and you'll
see that it's exactly the same as DDMS
the cool thing is this would allow you
to tell people that don't have the IDE
installed that allows them to run some
of these performance tools and
introspect some of the functionality
without requiring the full IDE install
or you know in bringing importing a
project and doing all those tough things
that maybe a tester might not want to do
or a project manager so so you can bring
up the performance tools using monitor
like this android device monitor or if
you're in eclipse you can show open
perspective dbms okay so this is what
the DDMS or monitor window looks like
you'll notice it on the left it has a
list of devices you currently have
running which allows you to select from
all those different devices on the top
right there's all sorts of different
functionality that allows you to
introspect different things within your
app now ddms is really designed for
in-depth performance monitoring so this
is where you're going to want to inspect
how your threads are running if you have
of if you have threads that aren't being
closed properly or your heap allocation
if you're getting out of memory errors
allocation tracker where your objects
are being allocated within your heap
network statistics get really in-depth
information about what calls are being
made when and what kind of data
throughput is going through those file
explorer allows you to it's a it's a GUI
that allows you to look on your phone
using you know it introspect your file
system you can then pull or push files
to the file system on your phone using
that then the emulator
is the tab I have exposed this allows
you to set you know if you want to set
latency on your device simulate a phone
call simulate location this is where you
would would do that so some important
things that I want to make sure
everybody well I guess we already
covered most of these things but the one
thing that most people can really use
out of this screen and by most people
this is not even developers is this
little icon right here this allows you
to select a device bring your app up on
that device you press that button it
will take a screenshot of whatever is
being shown on your device so that's
super useful because obviously we all
need to take screenshots for demos or
promotional materials upload pictures to
the Play market whatever this is much
easier than trying to press up and power
on a phone and just the right you know
time and then trying to get that file
off so that's a really useful aspect of
ddm asus is taking a screenshot ok so I
think we kind of already covered those
things the last tool that I really want
to talk about that I think people might
not be aware of but is super useful
especially for performance optimization
is hierarchy viewer so what this allows
you to do is this allows you to inspect
the visual hierarchy of your UI and see
where you might have extra layouts in
android the fewer layouts the better if
you have a bunch of nested layouts due
to the way that the view is measured and
drawn the more layouts you have the
longer it takes to render and that's
obviously bad that causes performance
problems so this very quickly allows you
to look at your UI
on a visual level and see what your
hierarchy looks like and try to
determine any places where you can
optimize the optimal layout is flat and
a shallow this is not as optimal layout
it's got lots of different levels and so
it really allows you very quickly to see
exactly how your UI is laid out and how
its performing in addition and
unfortunately can't really see in this
screenshot it actually shows you
measurement times in that pop up so you
can very quickly run the hierarchy
viewer on your UI see how long it took
to render make optimizations run
hierarchy viewer again and see how your
optimizations affected the layout times
in that project that I referenced
previously I have two layouts one's
called bad layout and one's called good
layout when you look at them on the
device itself they look exactly the same
the buttons are all placed in exactly
the same place the UI does exactly the
same thing however one of them was
written with a relative layout so it's
all very flat and not a lot of nested
layouts the other is written using a
bunch of nested layouts bunch of linear
layouts of horizontal and vertical
orientation all meshed together so I
encourage you guys to actually run those
two side-by-side and inspect what a good
layout looks like and what a bad layout
looks like the same exact layout in that
example runs twenty percent faster using
the relative layout so again it looks
exactly the same but as an optimized
version it runs almost a fifth faster
so the question is how many layers of
layout is considered optimal and the
answer is it depends you know there's no
hard and fast rules layouts can be
complicated and sometimes they require a
bunch of different nested layouts
sometimes that's the only way to get it
done to dealing with the weights or
other things so the answer is it depends
but the real answer to that is as few as
you can get away with yes the but the
fewer layers levels of layouts that you
have the better user experience the
faster your UI is going to render and
the less resources probably takes the
same resources but fewer layouts more
better okay I wanted to just touch on
some other performance tools we're
almost done here so just to let you guys
know that some other tools that I'm not
able to demo here but I want you guys to
be aware of so you know that they exist
first one is OpenGL tracer so this if
you're using OpenGL within your app this
allows you to trace very specifically
through all of your GL calls so that you
can see exactly what's happening through
after your throughout your code
rendering I don't do a lot of OpenGL
myself I am don't do that sort of
graphic stuff but really really useful
if you're doing OpenGL really really
useful to be able to see exactly what it
is that you're doing so again all these
tools are just allowing us to get a
closer look at how our code is operating
so that we really understand and that we
can optimize where it's most effective
pixel perfect viewer allows you to look
at very close renditions of your UI so
that you can isolate shadow problems or
any sort of dithering or other issues
that you might have
your UI network statistics we already
talked about that allows you very very
close understanding of exactly what's
happening with your network calls you
can trace the size of the calls the
duration etc etc a system information
gives you a really good overview of your
device the memory it's use the memory it
has available space on the device things
like that it shows you that in some
really nice charts so it's a really
clear visual representation of exactly
what your device is what resources are
available to your device
so the question is if you're dealing
with a app that might have might suck
battery or might use a lot of power does
the system information provide that I
don't know I'll look at that in a second
I don't know of a good tool to track
that there's a company in India that
does that
yeah so real quick we'll go through
these last ones and then I think we're
good to close us out so lint is a
automated test testing tool basically
it's going to in your code as it's live
it will flag certain things in your code
that are either wrong or that are just
bad so for instance like we talked about
before if you're using a hard-coded
string with in your code lint will go
through automatically and it'll put a
little flag next to that that says hey
you probably don't want to be using a
hard-coded string here and then when you
mouse over that and it will give you
remediation strategies and in some cases
will actually go ahead and fix those for
you so in this case lint will highlight
that highlight you will click on that
particular string and then it will
provide you the button that says export
this string to XML to strings.xml so
lint is run automatically it can also be
run as part of your build to flag things
it's much like PMD or fine bugs in the
Java world basically automated testing
tool to highlight patterns and not
functional problems but code problems
so the question is is there a tool that
will tell you what the minimum android
OS is to target and the answer is no
because that's fully dependent on you
you need to decide how you want to so
who you want to support so there's no
tool that can tell you that now it
obviously depends on the api's you need
to support and your customer base so but
there's no no rules for that that's
that's completely subjective it will
tell you if you have API issues and it
will allow you to it will tell you if
you're using an API that's not supported
in the version of the OS you're
targeting actually so that is one of the
things that it will tell you um monkey
is basically a tool that Allah is
designed to be if a thousand tiny
monkeys were using your app pressing it
all at the same time this is basically
chaos testing to see if a bunch of
different presses happen on your app
what would happen if it will crash
that'll cause issues monkey runner not
at all the same thing monkey runner is a
scripting tool that basically uses Perl
scripts to allow you to do automated UI
tests using this monkey runner scripting
tool really useful memory allocation
tracker now this is an eclipse tool but
it's built directly into the adt and
allows you to is the tools are built
directly into the adt you can dump a map
profile directly from DDMS this allows
you very very good inspection into the
memory of your app so it provides all
sorts of options to determine how your
heaps being allocated and will also
provide a bunch of different options for
how to improve your memory so that's an
eclipse tool but it's built directly
into the adt and is really valuable tool
to use the last one that i just want to
mention in
kind of have a dress as a high level a
little bit later this is a external
project an open source project called
sensor simulator project so we mentioned
with emulators there are certain things
that you can't emulate sensors being for
one you know what motion sensors or
touch other things this sensor simulator
project actually allows you to both
record sensor operations and play them
back automate out in an automated
fashion or if you just want to simulate
sensor operations meaning you know again
motion sensors or whatever it'll allow
you to simulate those on the emulator so
if if you're needing to write
functionality that the emulator can't
support using sensors that's a really
great project and a really great way to
to to make that happen okay I think
we're done I did want to make sure that
I put some reference points up on the
screen for where you can go to learn
more about the tools first one we
already put up there is the Android
developer tools official project site
tons of useful information there lots of
help articles and more importantly they
also have a their project plan what they
plan on doing what they plan on
supporting you can put help requests in
there you can put bug requests in there
they're very open about what they're
working on and what their plans are and
it's all contained in that on that
website really really useful stack
overflow I hope most of the people in
this room already know about it if you
have a question yeah someone someone has
already asked it on stack overflow and
you know hopefully has answered it
really useful there is a google group
for specifically for android developer
tools developers and there's the link
for that right now there's a lot of
noise about android studio and Gradle in
there so if you're working on either of
those two tools
that seems to be consuming most of the
most of the messages in that group but
the the tools guys the guys that work
for Google on the tools project they're
actively in these in that group
answering questions and helping people
so it's a great resource for researching
things if you haven't if you don't have
the answer last really great resource is
the Android developer tools essential
book available now from O'Reilly on
amazon com okay that's it I think we
already answered all the questions I
just wanted to make sure that people
have access to the thick github repo
slide share and then if you'd like to
follow me on twitter or circle me on
google+ i would love to connect so
thanks very much